Allen barges weighs 650 pounds more than
three times the weight of the average
u.s. male but his own confession he's
guilty of gluttony for 30 years
Allen was eating himself to death
it's 7:00 in the morning Allen barges is
leaving the hospital and heading home to
st. Thomas Pennsylvania
this electric winch is the easiest way
to transfer Allen's great bulk into the
ambulance
when Ellen was admitted into the
hospital four months ago he weighed 750
pounds
saddled with several hundred extra
pounds Allen's heart had a huge job
pumping blood around his enormous system
he collapsed after his body couldn't
take it anymore
now after bariatric surgery he's lost
100 pounds his aim is to lose another
300 so he can lead an active life again
in their 30 years of marriage Alan and
his wife Cindy have never been separated
it's a joy I got my baby back got my
honey back my best friend human legs
aren't built to support such a birdie so
Alan can't stand or walk he's a living
example of how too much fat can cripple
the body
puppy dogs all ready for you Alan has to
be manhandled through his own front door
it's a process in Cindy finds
distressing
[Applause]
they're carrying a lot of weight of the
way they have to get him in
this is very hard on me to watch my
husband go through this are these good
gentlemen who able to get him safely in
the house are they going to be able to
not hurt him it's very hard on him
mentally as well as physically
it takes six strong men to bring Allen
home to his wife you want your doggie
until he can lose enough weight to walk
again Allen is completely reliant on
others I hadn't been out of the house
for a year it got to the point I fell
down here in the bedroom don't know I
just won able to go anywhere
Cyndi tends to his every need food has
to be brought cooked prepared for him
has to be taken to him all his needs
personal needs are done for him in the
bedroom and we have to do everything for
him that bedroom
is his present right now
you